Researchers from the California Institute
of Technology in Pasadena have discovered
a brand new species of parasitic bacteria
that may play a role in gum disease because
it lives in human saliva.
And a recent poll suggests Americans expect
pizza delivery drones by the year 2036.
Which isn’t nearly soon enough!
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Geologists are making their own lava to generate
and study explosions.
Scientists from the University of Buffalo
are eager to understand how the interactions
of molten rock and water sometimes cause massive
explosions and sometimes times don’t.
Their recipe for lava includes basalt, a magnetic
induction furnace that heats up to 2,500 degrees
fahrenheit and after 3 to 4 hours, results
in 10-gallons of lava.
They pour it into a gravel formation and inject
water before it forms a crust to help learn
about the dangers of volcanoes near oceans,
lakes and ice.
How do you get this job?
The path to sustainable roads may be paved
with pig manure.
With 43 billion gallons of swine manure generated
every year, researchers at North Carolina
Agricultural and Technical State University
have created a pig manure sticky binder that
can make asphalt.
At only 56 cents per gallon its much cheaper
than petroleum and the manure stink is filtered
out during processing.
And the hope is for this bioadhesive to prevent
manure from getting into water supplies and
making people sick and instead put it to use
on the pig poop highway.
Using the last bit of shampoo may no longer
be a struggle.
While coatings to help the flow of food have
existed for a while, soap has been more difficult
due to its surface tension.
So a new plastic bottle lining developed at
Ohio State University features a microscopic
coating of y-shaped structures.
These structures then hold the soap droplets
above tiny pockets of air, preventing it from
touching the bottle and allowing it to glide
smoothly into your luxurious hair or onto
your luxurious body.
Being called a bird brain may now be a compliment.
Thought to have lower information-processing
capacity because of their size, Avian brains
were found to have significantly denser concentrations
of neurons than mammals.
Large parrots can have the same or even more
forebrain neurons than monkeys with larger
brains.
Allowing them to make and use tools, solve
problems, recognize themselves in mirrors,
and plan for their future needs.
You can follow the biggest fish in the world
online.
Conservation International scientists in Indonesia
are using satellite transmitters attached
to the dorsal fins of whale sharks to study
their migratory movements and diving behavior.
The real-time map allows anyone to see where
Moby, Mitch or any of the currently unnamed
sharks are located.
Moby’s diving record is more than a mile
beneath the surface.
And they’ve learned that while the whale
sharks are mostly homebodies, they have taken
mysterious road trips, one of which was 2,485
miles and they know that it wasn’t for mating…so
yeah…they don’t why.
The GEAR controller allows gamers to play
using their feet.
Gyorgy Levay, a devoted gamer, lost both of
his hands in 2011 due to a menengitis infection.
He and two other grad students from John Hopkins
designed a game interface capable of being
operated by the player's lower limbs.
Three sensors under the padding of the sandle-like
controller detect foot movements like tilting
or raising the heel which are then translated
to different commands in the game.
And so far they’ve successfully played Counter-Strike,
Fallout 4, and World of Warcraft.
Finally, 3.9 billon years ago a monster black
hole shredded a star and echoes of X-rays,
which first reach Earth on March 28, 2011,
have been used to map the black hole’s disk.
Researchers realized they were witnessing
the aftermath of tidal disruption event.
A star ripped apart by the monster black hole
at the galaxy's center.
Some of the stellar material fell toward the
black hole forming an accretion disk and a
jet pointed in our direction.
I’m gonna leave you with a programmable
and customizable walking robot named Marty
- and as always, thanks for watching.
You see the heterodynes are feeding back into
the stimulus reaction activators, causing
snaps of the motor control units.
Oh, that's good!
No, lady.
That's bad.
But your regenerative circuits are torn dyssynchronously
and that causes concatenation in the intermediate
amplifiers.
Oh, that's bad.
No, that's good!
Everyday in our homes and in our offices,
as well as in our motor cars, hundreds of
these little robots are doing more things
than we realize.
Taking care of the routine tasks and leaving
us free to live, work and play in greater
ease and comfort and safety.
I'm extremely excited to announce the launch
of The Curiosity Box!
Something Michael, Jake and I have been working
on for a really long time.
You may remember the past couple of years
we had Holiday Boxes that were filled with
exclusive Vsauce gears and other curious items.
Well, The Curiosity Box comes out quarterly
so when you subscribe, you get a brand new
one delivered to your door every three months.
Michael, Jake and I are literally working
on every single thing that goes into these
boxes.
This is Inq.
Inq is an octopus.
Inq is short for Inquisitive.
We love Inq.
Go to TheCuriosityBox.com to subscribe.
There's a link at the top of this video's
description to make it easier for you.
So get excited!
Get The Curiosity Box.
A portion of the proceeds go to Alzheimer's
research.
So if you love amazing things.
You love brains.
And you love Inq.
Go check it out!